are you sitting comfortably then I'll
begin a long long time ago in the case
of the Brothers Grimm try over 200 years
ago some very clever people wrote nice
stories of make-believe
such as Cinderella and Snow White in
which a handsome prince kissed a girl
who'd been poisoned by an evil witch
they clashed over lookest issues and who
was in a coma she was about to die so 7
of her closest friends who would make
that born with dwarfism begged him to do
it but the prince was a naughty man he
didn't ask permission before kissing the
comatose girl indeed he didn't ask
whether she was actually a man just
self-identifying or lgbtq+ now some very
cross campaigners some of whom are
wealthy beyond the dreams of Croesus
thanks to starring in similar stories
are stamping their Luba tall plaid feet
and even banning their own children from
watching the film yes boys and girls if
they take offense this easily it's safe
to assume they're unlikely to live
happily ever after
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm very aware of what I'm marinating my
child in so there's a couple of like
stories just seem wise that I'm not I'm
not cool with it's like no it's not cool
to like wait for a rich guy to save you
like save yourself it no it is never
cool for any man that you don't know to
kiss you in your sleep without consent
not okay no never give your voice up for
a man absolutely not not okay I
understand what she's on about but I
don't you can make any difference I mean
one of the shocking things you've had
kids singing about boys and girls is
just how different they are quite
quickly you know I always remember the
first girls party we ever had everybody
was nice and polite and these boys came
in and I always thought lately brought
up the syphon today I then years later
became chairman of an animation company
and any job you had no I most helpful
what was really interesting is the word
boys good boys and girls toys and it was
a straightforward is that wonder what
you do I'm Thomas the Tank Engine selves
to young boys
I mean it's a girls that you bit
ourselves to young boys and never I'm
not sure that the influence she wants to
have won't bounce back on her right okay
okay truce and then actually I
understand what she's on about but I
said I'm not sure it actually would okay
Jude well you know what it's funny you
you know I am a proud feminist but I
think this is why feminism gets a bad
name because sometimes it is just too
over the top
bloody how it is a fairy tale and now if
all you were doing is reading your
children fairy tales and we have a
problem but if you're making sure that
you're countering that narrative with
something else
then there's no problem if you discuss
it with if you read it to your child
possibly your daughter you then can
explore issues of concern I don't want
to be talking about that that early on
and also there are other things you can
then make sure you're telling them about
women have done great things in history
whatever all don't take samples from
strangers exactly nobody tells you that
you've got to read that story about 200
times to this child so you're not gonna
discuss it yeah oh you really want to do
is go to sleep final point it's actually
also quite hypocritical of Keira
Knightley because she made those
comments while actually promoting a
Disney film The Nutcracker and the
forums where she plays a sugarplum fairy
nobody feminists about that
fairytales are supposed to be about
fantasy they're not supposed to be about
sending subliminal messages about
feminism and about independence and I
just didn't the greatest irony in all of
this
it's Karen night this is a girl who is
done extraordinary well with with her
incredible beauty but her not so
incredible acting talents her no her
success is the big fairy tale eeeh and
she doesn't actually say dan I think you
I think the millions of people who go to
see our movies might say different I
thought little girls would be far more
influenced by the way flight models
these thing in magazines than by the
characters in in the inner Disney movie
don't you say I think I complete success
you sure well when I was in this topic I
was almost well I was ready to go while
I had a bloody nonsense you know kicking
off because someone's kiss and Snow
White and all the rest of it and then
I've really thought about Disney movies
now my childhood and sorry mom if you're
watching but my childhood wasn't ideal
but to say it mildly and I did use to
watch Disney movies and read books and
as I sit here now if I'm honest with
myself and I can't believe I'm about to
admit this but if I'm honest I would say
that my outlook expectations and desires
have been in in some ways shaped by
Disney movies well I do I do I'm a
hopeless romantic I'm often disappointed
in relationships with products or
because yeah because I'm being
completely honest here like I said
Prince Charming was good you genuinely
believe in child like for example like I
I one of my face and this is a really
strange conversations needs to be having
because I'm like my brain right now it's
saying all dirt say this and challenge
this and but I when I watch a Disney
movie it does something to me it does it
gives me goosebumps it makes me feel a
certain way and one of my favorite
movies is up I don't know if anyone's
ever watched
oh and I come from a home that's not you
know it was a it was not a pleasant
place to be when I was growing up and
when you see up it's this great story of
this couple
and they come together and they live
this great life in the adventure and and
I used to watch stuff like that I just
think I want must be nice just to pursue
Greg's point you honestly thought that
I'm being facetious a prince will come
along it's not necessarily about a
prince coming along it's about I was in
an unhappy place for the child yeah it
was very much escapism and I feel almost
bad because I know my mom will be
watching this and I don't want to cause
upset but the true from the reality of
it is I used to read like story books
roll down a lot as escapism I used to
watch Disney movies a lot as escapism
and even now at the age that I am at I
do still have a small part of me that
has this romantic notion and it is
shaped by things about Charlesworth
happy-ever-after what's wrong with
wishing for that you know how the kids
today reconcile harry and megan you know
there was a girl who was a restaurant
hostess she couldn't afford but also
should we tell kids not to read
Shakespeare because Hey
newsflash fermion jeunesse I completely
don't agree with banning Disney movie is
like completely do not agree she's just
stopping her daughter I guess what I'm
trying to say is there is a part of of
Mickey and maybe and I'd be fascinated
I'm fascinated and on Swit so if you're
watching this and you do understand what
I'm saying it doesn't tell us because
there is a part of me that has been
shaped by that but it goes beyond just
isn't it Disney isn't it I mean I mean
the truth is we promote certain I mean
you go to the average say drama school
and look at the women in that drama
school and they are disproportionately
beautiful yes
what society society chooses what it
sees as beautiful people and that's what
we promote as being I mean I remember
when I was in London weekend - the head
of domicile she's a good actress she
doesn't mind playing ugly wears whereas
most women didn't want to play ugly what
is the play you know just one quick
thing and then hand straight to you
Carol um I think the point I'm making
point you made there's a really valid
point and it goes back to what I said
originally
that if you don't have anything positive
to counter a Disney movie so in your
life you came from a traumatic home and
you had a very difficult childhood then
the problem is there was no balance but
if you come from a more secure family
and you are actually making sure that
you're countering that Disney narrative
then it isn't a problem the other issue
can I just say tuesd other things the
other problem the problem I have with
Disney films is number one that the
majority of women in them or the girls
portrayed in them are scantily clad
that's actually no good and what's also
interesting is in terms of children's
book there's a statistic and we can
bring it up from the observer at Nielsen
in 2017 which found that out of a
hundred of the top children's books the
lead characters were 50% more likely to
be male or I guess we don't have enough
of Nikki Lurie next week when we're
doing Beauty and the Beast played by
June Sarpong and Greg Dyke I'll let you
decide anyway it's now time for straight
something of the week so it's no secret
that most MPs will do almost anything
for bit of publicity but the Honourable
member for Litchfield Michael fabricant
is hoping that the sight of his
honorable member will be enough to
encourage people to raise money for
hospice in his constituency the naked
cycle ride is a good way of raising
money a naked bike ride from Litchfield
to Whittington would be a beautiful
thing I would uncover all sorts of parts
that I've never seen before
I'm told that naked cycle riding is both
healthy and liberating
[Music]
yeah I feel sorry I feel sorry for the
person who had to actually use that bike
after for that brazenness that mr.
fabric and you are are straight stripper
of the week I think he has to pay us
we're having to see that thing